so here's my idea write this number that
we've just created it's the feet okay
it's how many feet there are right which
means that what you've got left over
like the point for 13 or the point 9 05
or the point for one or at cetera okay
that's how much of a foot I need to
convert two inches okay that's how much
of a foot I need to convert dangerous so
I need just that little bit right the
leftover bit so here's what I'm going to
do I'm just going to go over to the
right a little bit not that fun ok so
I'm going to say I'm leftover bit that's
what I'm going to call it okay later i'm
going to show you how to hide all of
this i'm just giving it a name that's
descriptive so i know what to do okay so
i'm gonna say equals right and the left
over bit will be the whole height right
that sell their d2 and I should take
away can anyone tell me what to put it
it should be this cell here right I was
I was so close right um I want to take
away all of the feet all of the whole
feet right like that ok so that's point
41 feet left over that's the leftover
beer and that'll be point nine leftover
bit for one and so on ok so if patients
it all the way down okay so look at all
these bits so this is how many feet I
left over right but I want this not in
feet I want it in inches so the leftover
bit is the actual height minus how many
whole feet I can fit into them okay so
how do i convert feet into inches how
many feet are there so how many inches
are there in one foot do we know it's 12
right 12 inches in one foot so to turn
this leftover bit into inches I should
it should i divide
multiply can I call a friend um I want
to take a small number see the decimal
number and I want to make it I want to
make it bigger because when I say five
foot nine I've got a whole number yeah
so i'm going to say equals and i'm going
to multiply it by 12 that'll turn feet
into inches all right i'll put that in
again so I've got that leftover bit and
I'm multiplying it by 12 ok ok now I'm
actually going to upgrade this a little
bit because as you can see when i hit
antar I've got this Rio looking decimal
and we still don't say decimals like
this we don't say five foot four point
nine six right we I guess what would you
say in this situation I think in this
case now this is a bit tricky 4.96
that's almost five inches it's almost
five inches right so I think in this
case I'd say five foot five that's what
I'm closest to i'm actually not closer
to five foot four ok so i'm not
automatically rounding down here I'm
just rounding right so I'm going to
upgrade this formula in a bit to do the
rounding for me I'll say round that and
how many decimal places do i won I don't
want any 0 ok so i'll leave that there
for a second I'll even write it for you
I'm taking that leftover bit I convert
it into inches firstly by x 12 and then
secondly i rounded I Randall off to know
dis place to a whole number yeah
yes good question can someone answer why
are we rounding down always down here
but in this column over here this is a
great question why are we just rounding
and not rounding down does anyone have
an idea hmm i'm actually going to let
that question sit for a minute because i
think it's a really good question and if
you can't answer it then hot on a second
view these are height we tell our people
are high all the time this is something
we understand why can't we wrap our head
around why one rounds down and one
rounds up or down i'll let you ever
think about it let's hit that top and
then we'll complete this okay so five
there copy it and paste it all the way
down like so they had something
interesting there which is that that
goes to a 12 right which is actually a
whole foot isn't it ok let us interpret
that in a second so I have all the
inches now so now to tidy this a bit up
right what I'm going to do is I don't
want any of this decimal rubbish right
that's not useful to me so I want you to
put your cursor up on the top of this
column here where it says d ok if you're
right click there a whole bunch of
options come up including hi ok right
down the bottom there you can hide that
whole column because it was kind of like
our working out right but we don't need
the working out in the final answer for
this we just want to present it neatly
ok so if I hide that one like so I can
do the same for this call of the F right
so if I right click on F and I'll hide
that one as well tada now I've got
everything nice and neat I've got five
foot five oops sorry five foot five 5 11
another 5 foot 5 5 foot 7 4 foot 1 6
foot 5 605 oh and a no no no no you get
the idea
now there is one last arm or two last
little funny things here right so you're
at these two these people who are well
their heights in feet and inches are
kind of unusual right what's happened
what's happened to you 4 4 12 but we
wouldn't say four foot 12 would wear or
five foot 12 for that learner I think we
would actually say five foot in this
case and in this case we would say six
foot right this is ever so close to
actual six foot right but it just
rounded down a little bit right so this
formula it's not perfect but by and
large that's pretty alright there's six
foot 16 with nothing's alright there's
[ __ ] ten that's me ok so we used a
whole bunch of formulas in order to
generate all that for us and it does all
automatically whether it's some 26
people or 260 people or however many it
can do all that work for us ok